foreign
good afternoon everybody I'm Adrian Dix
I'm BC's minister of Health joining me
is Dr Bonnie Henry VC's provincial
Health officer uh we're today offering
uh a greeting and a a this greeting but
also this briefing on the territories of
the musqueam of the Squamish of the
slave of two First Nations we are
honored to be here on their lands uh and
uh today we're going to have the
opportunity to talk about issues
relating to covid-19 to respiratory
illness to vaccination
and uh and ask answer the questions that
you have on a number of issues I'm sure
you may have heard earlier today the BCE
Public Service employees or will no
longer be required to provide proof of
vaccination against covet 19. this
decision was announced by the head of
the public service Shannon Salter
earlier today and I would say that the
decision was based as all of you know on
the very high level of x in the BC
public service and the current state of
the pandemic and it reflects
what a lot of employers are doing and
the overall the advice of Public Health
I should also say that the vaccine
requirement in health care and Public
Health Care continues to be in place
it's based of course on provincial
Health order it continues and it will
continue it reflects the fundamental
need to protect the most vulnerable
people
especially people in acute care and in
long-term care but many more in our
Province and and so well changes are
being made by Employers in other
workplaces in healthcare the vaccine
requirement that that provides
protection that BC LED on during an
earlier stage of the pandemic will
continue to be in place as all of you
know tomorrow
will Mark the third anniversary of the
Declaration of a pandemic by the World
Health Organization on March the 11th
2020 that it has been
a long three years
I think I would just reflect on all of
those who have suffered loss in those
period in this period all of those
who've suffered loss directly from covet
19. suffered loss in our in the public
health emergency it is the overdose
Public Health Emergency that was greatly
impacted by the fact of covid-19 in BC
all of those who have had ongoing had
health impacts and ongoing Health
impacts or have a sense of loss for
things that they were unable to do
but it's also a time to recognize all of
the things that were done together by
all people in BC by nurses and doctors
and health science professionals and
health care workers of course but by
people in every town
in every place in BC in every region of
BC who took action not just to protect
one another but to support one another
in difficult times who reached out when
people were isolated who supported their
family members their friends and often
people they did not know but found a way
to do it all the steps that were taken
this is a recognition I think this three
years of who we are as a community and
who we are as a province the record on
covid-19 of British Columbia compared to
other jurisdictions is an excellent
record and I think people understand
that we frequently describe these things
in terms of how did the government do or
how did Public Health do but truly if
it's the case that we have done well in
spite of all that we lost in this period
it's because of everyone listening to me
and everyone else in BC who took the
action to get vaccinated to protect one
another who supported one another in the
in the community I do want to spend and
take a particular moment though to
acknowledge the work of health care
workers in our Province who I think have
faced exceptional circumstances to
Public Health emergencies and just to
note how challenging it remains today
last night at midnight at 11 59 there
were 9
927 people admitted to public hospitals
in BC which by any standard is a very
high number
in the last weeks the most recently
recorded weeks we had did more surgeries
in the public health care System than we
had ever done in this time of year
before in fact
almost 250 more surgeries than we did
for the very same week in 2019. before
the pandemic in spite of the changes we
had to make more diagnostic procedures
delivering more care to more people
and that continues the strain of three
years of the pandemic has been
exceptional and our health care workers
have done extraordinary work this
morning I had the honor a dear friend of
our families myself and my wife Renee
Sarah Genie saclikar Dr Paul warts who's
one of those health care workers passed
away and we attended virtually a
memorial service he's gone back to
Ontario and passed away Dr rorich was an
outstanding scientist an outstanding
psychiatrist whose patients benefited
enormously from his care and gift
and his care and gift especially in the
time of pandemic especially with the
challenges people face around mental
health issues with specialness
symbolizes all the work that all the
people do and we think of Paul today
taking it from us too young at 51 from
cancer all that he contributed in these
last years of his life to make life
better for the patients he served and
that's true of health care workers and
long-term care and the people that kept
our hospitals clean and three years into
this pandemic let us raise our hands to
all of them recognize all of them thank
all of them for their work and their
contribution this continues to be as all
of you know a very challenging time with
respect to covid-19 yesterday there were
205 people positive for covid-19 in
hospitals across BC and others who are
facing the challenge of it and other
respiratory illnesses and so we continue
to deal with covid-19 and we'll continue
to do so and it's my honor to introduce
someone who has been with British
Columbians through this last three years
and continues to be on this issue to
talk about our approach to vaccinations
this spring which continues to focus on
a fundamental principle fundamental to
issues of vaccination and their
requirements fundamental to when we
receive vaccinations which is vaccines
that protect first those who are most
vulnerable to covet 19. it's my honor to
introduce Dr Bonnie Henry
thank you very much and good afternoon
everybody
um
it is starting a little bit to feel like
spring here in Vancouver and other parts
of the province and that is a welcome
reminder to us that we are nearing the
end of respiratory season although we're
not yet out of the woods I want to thank
everybody who stepped up and did get
their vaccination their booster dose for
covid in the fall but also their
influenza vaccination it has made a
tremendous difference on the the impact
that this respiratory season has had on
our hospitals and our Health Care system
and on our health and our communities it
has made a major difference
but covid-19 is still with us and we're
still seeing higher levels than we saw
for some time and as expected we're
starting to see a bit of an increase in
influenza B and I think I talked about
this a couple of times as we went into
respiratory season we tend to see a bit
of a later surge often of influenza B
usually affecting younger people and and
can be spread within their families We
Know That vaccine continues to offer
protection and to protection against the
influenza B strains as well but we are
thankfully other respiratory infections
like RSV have continued to decline so
that is an important and a good reminder
that we need to remain Vigilant in our
efforts to protect ourselves our loved
ones our communities and our families
and distant food staying up to date on
on Covert vaccines so where are we now
with that
as many people are aware the national
advisory committee on immunization
did come up with a statement about
recommendations about who needs to get a
vaccine in the spring period and we've
had a lot of discussions at that time at
the national level with Nasi on our
special advisory committee and and we've
looked with our immunization committee
here in BC at our data on Immunity on
infection on illness on who's ending up
in hospital to try and find that best
place of where we can provide the
maximum protection for those who need it
in this coming months
so we will be offering a spring booster
program aligning pretty much with the
guidance from the national advisory
committee so this means the focus will
be on protecting people at highest risk
of severe illness and they are also the
people we know that their immunity the
protection that they get from vaccine or
from combinations of vaccine and
infection tends to go down more quickly
it doesn't get as high in older people
and it tends to wane or decrease more
quickly so the focus will be on adults
in our Province who are 80 and over and
if you're an indigenous person in the
province we've always made some
compensation for understanding the the
risks for indigenous people so that'll
be 70 and older for indigenous people
those are people who we know should get
a booster in the coming months we'll
also be focusing on seniors and
long-term care and over this last three
years of course we know that our seniors
and elders and long-term care have
really borne the brunt of this virus and
we know that their immunity is wanes
more quickly and this also includes
seniors with complex medical needs and
alternative level of care and and Home
Care
as well the focus will be on on people
18 and older who are moderately to
severely immune compromised and and what
we call that in BC is our clinically
extremely vulnerable groups so very
early on we knew that there were some
people who needed additional doses of
vaccine to get up to even the level of
protection that most people have with a
with a strong immune system
and we also know that protections from
vaccination and from infections and the
combination decreases more quickly in
this group as well
additionally and this is where we've
varied a little bit from the nasty
recommendations based on our data here
so we're suggesting that anybody's 60
and over our indigenous people who are
50 and over who have not yet had
covid-19 and that could be from a rapid
test or having consider having symptoms
of covid-19 they can consider getting a
booster dose this spring and so why do
we say that and why are we not saying go
out and get it there's a couple of
reasons we are learning a lot about the
immune system about the vaccinations
about the durability of protection and
about what we call hybrid immunity so
that protection that you get from having
both vaccinations and in some cases
infection on top of that and the the
vaccines that you know that we have have
proven to provide good strong protection
but it decreases over time and it
changes the depending on the interval
you've had between vaccines how strong
your immune system is and whether you've
had an infection recently
so I'll talk a little bit more about
that in a minute so for everybody who
was recommended in this spring booster
program the dough should be at six
months or more after you've had either
your previous infection or your last
dose so that means for the most part
we're going to be starting in April and
as you know we wanted to make sure that
seniors and long-term care had the best
protection possible when covet was
increasing in the fall so most of the
long-term care homes for example started
in October and so we'll be looking at
April as the time frame for starting
this campaign
so for everybody else not in that
category our data here in the province
the serial prevalence data that we've
reported on and the data on severe
illness and hospitalizations shows that
having had a primary series plus really
importantly a booster continues to
provide strong protection and having
protection against infection goes down
quite a bit but that protection against
severe illness and hospitalization
remains very high and we know that
giving an additional booster from some
of the data from other countries and
from here as well doesn't add a whole
lot of protection
um we also know that hospitalization
when we look at our data what we see is
there's a bit of a step up for people in
their 60s and that's why we've included
that that recommendation to consider the
booster if you're 60 and older
um it's a step up again at 70 but where
we really see the increases people over
age 80 and you can look at the data on
the bccdc website and you see that
people who are hospitalized and more
severely affected by this virus continue
to be our elders and seniors
so our our zero prevalence data so what
that tells us and that tells us that
across the age Spectrum we have a really
high level of immunity that's for many
people a combination of immune immunity
that they get from vaccination plus
having been exposed to and infected with
covid-19 so what does that look like if
we look at the Spectrum across the age
groups for people under age 50 as many
as 80 to 90 percent of people have some
combination of of protection from both
vaccination and infection so that's good
and what we're learning as we're going
through this whole thing globally is
that that level of protection your
immune system remembers that for a
longer period of time so why you might
not why you may still get infected the
second part of our immune system and
I've talked about this before what we
call them memory cells cell mediated
immunity our system is primed so when
you are exposed to the virus it can
rapidly ramp up and protect you from
getting more severe illness stop the
virus from causing more infection cells
so that's
um and that is something that we most of
us have here particularly younger people
um so that's why we're not saying right
now that you need to have a dose and why
we're saying it's better to hold off and
and make sure that you're ready when
when we head into the fall and so
there's still many things that we don't
yet know
um the other thing that I'll say is when
we talk about the immune system we it's
not all or nothing so we do see
decreasing but that doesn't mean we have
no protection and that we're exposed to
the virus again what it means is that on
average in the population the the risk
of getting infected once you've been
exposed may go down to half but you
still have really good protection you
still have better than we had before and
that buffer is global now so we are
seeing the major changes in the virus
that we were seeing even a year ago so
we've had for over a year now Omicron
and different variations of Omicron and
the virus is becoming less severe
because globally we have that level of
protection but we're not we're we're
we're not sort of at the end of the
pandemic yet we're still emerging from
that so this spring program I believe is
going to be it's in response to what
we're seeing right now with a relatively
high level of coveted circulation and
still some changes happening in the
virus over time I also think that as we
go into next respiratory season so
thinking ahead to the fall we'll be in a
very similar situation we may have new
vaccines and we may have new vaccines
that are developed to respond to the
changes in the virus that we're likely
to see over the next few months and I
hope we'll have vaccines that maybe have
influenza and covid together so those
are the things that we'll be watching
we'll be watching our data here in BC
and globally and we'll be making
recommendations as we head into the fall
the other things I want to say is you
know that we know
um that this protection is holding up
now for over eight months and that's how
long it's been since many people got
their bivalent booster in the fall and
so we'll continue to watch that
we also know that vaccination and
there's increasing evidence of this
vaccination is a very good protection
against the long-term effects of covid
or long covet symptoms and that's really
important too so this goes to a couple
of other things which will be no
surprise to hear me say that
unvaccinated people remain significantly
higher risk of getting coveted of
getting sick with covet of being
hospitalized with covid and so I I
encourage anybody who has not yet
received the vaccine to to talk to a
health care provider talk to your
pharmacist it is not too late to get the
protection that's going to help you for
the years to come because this virus is
going to be with us for the foreseeable
future
and on that note we've also got more and
more evidence from around the world and
here in BC that the bivalent booster so
the one that we can add in the fall that
started in the fall that has both the
original strain and the Omicron specific
strains that does give you longer better
protection against what's happening
right now circulating right now so if
anybody has not yet had a bifail booster
you should get that now as well so you
can get that from your pharmacist from
the public health clinic you can go
online and make an appointment today
and of course we encourage anybody who's
not yet been vaccinated and we have
vaccines now for people six months and
older to get their booster now
else who's not in the category that I
just talked about and and really feels
that they want to have a booster this
spring I encourage you to talk to your
health care provider or the pharmacist
about and to go to the bccdc website and
to look at some of the information that
I've just talked about and make a
decision with your vaccine provider
whether it's right for you or not and
you can also phone the call center and
we can provide advice to you on that as
well
so as always we'll continue to monitor
the data and look at risks and changes
to the virus and as I mentioned this is
still a pandemic response to address the
data that shows us that older people
have more waning of protection and less
hybrid protection and there is still a
moderate risk of Cova that's circulating
right now
as I said we don't yet know what the
rest of this year will bring but as
Global immunity increases there is less
risk of a brand new virus to which we
have no protection but much more likely
to have more variants of what we're
seeing circulating now
and I believe we will need to have
another dose as we head into next
respiratory season and that may over
time turn into an annual booster or an
annual dose that we'll have to have
before respiratory season or in my more
optimistic days I hope that with our
vaccine technology we might get a pan
covered vaccine within the next period
of time and maybe we'll only need to
have a dose that will last us for longer
than five or ten years even
so that part is speculation I don't know
yet and we keep learning about this
virus but that's what I think we're
heading towards
I also want to take a moment to talk
about uh treatments for covet so as we
know some of the monoclonal antibody
treatments have not yet been shown to be
effective with the Omicron variant but
paxlovic continues to be a treatment
that is available and that works and
protects people at highest risk it is
not a Panacea in that it is a
challenging drug and it has many
interactions with other common
medications that people are at higher
risk of having severe illness are off
and on as well so it is a such a
discussion between a clinician and an
individual who's at risk about receiving
paxlovid and what we have in in the
province we established early on in this
pandemic was the covet Therapeutics
committee and I have asked them to go
back and re-look as more evidence on the
benefits of paxlovid have been shown and
as we've gotten more information and
more comfortable and confidence in in
using
um this medications that we expand the
availability and I know in some
provinces they've made it available for
people 50 and above I think where the
evidence that I see it shows is really
it's for people over age 70 that's the
group that we see being hospitalized
that bump up and hospitalization and
older people and I'm hopeful that they
will be making it more available as you
know you can receive it from by
prescription from your provider across
the province in pharmacies across the
province or you can call the the
a11 to receive advice about whether it's
available for you
so we are as of tomorrow officially
three years into the pandemic
and it has been a long and challenging
time and I know it has affected all of
us across this province across this
country and globally
and I also know that everybody in this
province has sacrificed in ways big and
small we've talked a lot about how the
impacts of both the virus and the
measures that we've put in place to deal
with this virus have impacted our
seniors and Elders across this province
I also think a lot about young people
who've gone through such a challenging
time at times in their lives when these
Milestones that Mark
changes and transitions have not been
able to be celebrated in the same way
we have asked a lot of people in British
Columbia and I am so grateful to
everyone who did their part to support
and care for each other including
following Public Health advice and
getting vaccinated as the best
protection you have
and as I believe we are emerging there
is still change and there's still
uncertainty to come and we'll be here to
try and give us a give the best advice
that we have
and on that note I do know that spring
break is coming up for a lot of people
very soon and I do want to remind people
of the very basics of staying away from
others if you're sick you know
particularly you know that's if you're
not feeling well maybe skip that visit
to somebody who's more at risk like your
Elder grandparents or others
covering your mouth when your cough is
still important and cleaning your hands
regularly these are things that that we
should be ingrained in us and wearing a
mask in those situations where you're in
indoor spaces you may be around people
who are more at risk
but we are emerging and I believe ever
so slowly thanks to everybody in this
province we are moving into the light
and I'll stop so thank you very much and
we're happy to take your questions
please press star one to enter the queue
that's star one to ask a question for
media in the room please line up at the
microphone provided and please make sure
to provide us with your full name and
Outlet media will be limited to one
question and one follow-up we will be
starting in the room today do we have
anyone asking please go ahead
thank you for this uh my name is
Jennifer Maher from Canada my question
is for
um Minister dicks about the Olympic
medication
um back in January we learned that
British Columbia's your ministry was
investigating why U.S citizens were
fighting an early 10 of prescriptions in
the province for this diabetes drug also
used as a weight loss treatment and my
question is in French
we see
uh Plato permanence
[Music]
only opportunity to don't ever
on Premier League
[Music]
foreign
then the key benefits the publicity
Wireless
[Music]
me full surround record
event
[Music]
foreign
thank you
do we have any other questions in the
room
please go ahead Francis from Vancouver
sign in Province prime minister Dix if
you don't mind please can you please
tell me what has changed that you are
allowing people that that already been
fired from their jobs to come back what
is the you know the the nurses the
doctors that that they worked before in
the uh in the medical field and refused
the vaccine they've been dismissed so
are you taking them back now they can
come back to work or they still uh
dismissed so just to clarify the public
health orders the provincial Health
officer orders for health care workers
in our system remain in place so that
has not changed
one question is uh Bill 36 that was
passed and can you just explain how it's
going to affect the future of the
doctors and nurses that are not going to
get the uh the uh the vaccines that are
coming or the vaccine that's already
here
um how it's going to affect them if they
don't want to continue taking shots for
foreseeable future Bill 36 has nothing
to do with it zero nothing
and so
um it just has nothing to do with it you
will note that the provincial Health
orders and the actions we've taken take
to have taken place on the existing
Health Professions act nothing will
change in that respect although the
process is made more clear in the
legislation but it's the same
um I said very clearly yeah Dr Henry has
repeated I repeated the change today was
for the public service right not for the
Health Care System the requirement to be
vaccinated continues in the Health Care
system and it will continue in the
Health Care system with respect to Bill
36 it has nothing to do with that some
people have been promoting
um
that view online and they are not
correct so step back with Bill 36
a significant process and a review by an
international expert named Harry Kane
than an all-party review myself the
liberal critic the green party critic
with a unanimous report that has been
implemented here in addition to that
thousands of people participated in
public process 47 and a half hours of
legislative debate and what the what it
does is something that journalists have
been long asking for but members of the
public as well is it provides
significantly more transparency and
efficiency to the regulation of health
professionals which is well over a
hundred thousand people right so that's
what Bill 36 does it's not about it
makes no changes to those vaccination
questions we put forward and uh and to
suggest it does is just to be contrary
to the to the truth
Mark tomorrow in hindsight is there
anything you would have done differently
over those three years
that's always the question
um you know it's it's so challenging I
mean I we were talking
um at an immunization Forum just the
other day or sorry the the covid um task
force meeting just the other day about
you know what are the things
you know I think as a global Community
had we had a better support of China
early on being able to to stop this
before it became the global tragedy that
it did is something that
um I hope we don't lose sight of given
the geopolitical situation we're in now
I think when I think back about what
we've done and how we've come through
this
all of the challenges really were in
being able to communicate changes in
ways that people understood and you know
part of that is my feelings of of
communication and that's been the
hardest part is you know how do you find
that that balance of doing just enough
and I talked about harms and I know I
mean this virus has been so hard on some
people in our population and the
measures that we've put in place have
been hard and they're not the same
people always always that are affected
and you know how do we do
um and and I recognize the harms that
both sides caused and and trying to find
that right balance has been the burden
that we've borne over this last three
years so I think if anything I wish I
could have communicated why we were
making some changes better
okay for our next question we're going
to go to the phones
um our first caller on the phone is
Richard zusman Global News please go
ahead
I'm having some problems with
connectivity here so I'm hoping that you
can hear me can you hear me Dr Henry yes
we can
yeah awesome thank you
um two questions for you because it
wouldn't be a coping briefing we've got
multiple questions
long term is the Assumption now that
there will be full campaigns with a
potential coveted flu shot together and
that will be the one time a year
potentially that someone will receive a
covid shot is that the Assumption you're
working under and and I I want to
understand
fundamentally
why lift the Mandate in the public
sector in essence ending one of the
remaining mandates and not the ongoing
vaccine mandated in the Health Care
System sure okay let me talk about the
first one first
um
the the short answer is we don't know
yet I think that's what we're probably
in for this year and you know I've
talked about how the oscillations in in
what we're seeing in terms of infections
and surges has been getting less and
less as we have this this buffer of
immunity in the population and the
buffer of immunity protects those people
whose immune system doesn't respond as
well to vaccine and it provides
protection to those people who have not
yet been vaccinated but if they do get
infected they're much more likely to get
hospitalized or get very severely ill so
for the next year I think we're still in
a transition where there's much that we
don't yet know that's what the spring
booster is we know that there are some
people who are likely to benefit from it
most of us are actually doing pretty
okay right now as we're getting the data
I mean the challenge is we'd like to
have the data ahead of time to know what
to do but we it's generating new
information as time goes on so
um you know last week we only had eight
months and two weeks worth of
information now we have eight months and
three weeks worth of information and and
so that is changing still so my best
guess right now is that we're likely to
have a recommend a dose for everybody
going into respiratory season and I
suspect we'll do it and you know this is
me
um just using my bested thinking right
now unless things change and they have
changed that will likely do similar to
what we do for influenza where broadly
recommended but really focus on those
people who who need it most so that's
this year what's going to happen in the
following year I I hope we won't need to
consider spring boosters that will see
the the oscillations and the sort of
settling into the respiratory the
seasonal pattern more clearly next year
and there's still a lot of work being
done on on vaccines with the the sharing
of both the Brain Trust around the world
and the new technology that has been
really rapidly Advanced and we
understand a lot more now so I can only
speculate as far as you know what what's
happening in April and May and then what
I think my best guess for the fall this
year and and then we'll go from there
and if there's major changes in between
then we'll try and address those as they
arise so the difference between uh you
know what's happened today in the the
Public Service Agency is the type of
workplaces we're talking about and you
may recall a year ago and two years ago
when we were talking about vaccine
mandates and it is a risk assessment
done by employers about the risks in
their settings their employment settings
and the Public Service Agency we had
many conversations about the roles that
people play the protection of workers in
their workplace many of them are
public-facing workers and they made the
decision as employers to have this in
place for employees across the Public
Service Agency
and they've made the decision and yes I
was involved in providing advice about
risk now given the high rates of
immunization and given what we're seeing
in terms of the population and the
transmission of covid that decision was
made by the public service agency to to
remove those mandates
my responsibility and responsibility of
the minister but our public health and
my advice applies to Health Care
settings to the public health care
setting and those provincial Health
officer orders remain in place because
that is the highest risk setting both
for healthcare workers and for our
patients and residents in our care so
those mandates remain in place as we are
not yet through this respiratory season
and we're not yet out of that highest
risk period for those most vulnerable
people and I just hold my hands up to my
colleagues in healthcare across this
province who have so banded together to
do the best that they can for each other
and for the people that we care for
Richard did you have a follow-up
doctor I'm just trying to figure out on
the Nuance of what you just said at the
end there like is there a chance that
that mandate will be lifted my
understanding was that the sense from
you was that it would be permanent that
the covid-19 vaccines would permanently
be be added to health care workers
um professional contracts so just on
that but but also for Minister dicks uh
as we see respiratory illnesses and go
down we're still seeing in some rural
communities
um emergency rooms having to close
because of lack of staff are you worried
about
um the long-term challenges in rural
communities that even as we get back up
to high Staffing levels there are still
areas like Merit and others where they
don't have enough staff to ensure the
health care services for those
communities
the the provincial Health officer orders
I hope at some point will be able to
Sunset but yes we are looking at you
know how important is it to have
immunization and protection of
healthcare workers of each other and in
healthcare settings so I don't expect
that something that to be something that
will change and we're looking at what
does that mean in terms of policies and
and regulations within the health care
sector
thank you
and just to be clear Richard I don't
expect it to change either I I would say
with respect to the challenges facing
Health Care in uh in BC and in all
jurisdictions if you spend any time
looking at any jurisdiction uh in the
world of the Public Health Care System
you see some of the same challenges we
have as I mentioned earlier uh 9927
people in in hospital admitted to
hospital in BC Which is less than when I
was here at the beginning of January
which is 10 226 which is about the
height at that time but still by any
standards high in general during the
pandemic in 20 and 21 and the first part
of 22 we're seeing Hospital senses in
the 94 9500 range but not in the 9900
range and that's a significant
difference and you think currently all
the patients at St Paul's Hospital are
about
426 the difference between 95 and 9927
is about that so it's it's significant
we have dramatically and effectively
through Health Human Resources actions
increase the number of healthcare
workers in BC you've seen the results in
Primary Care in the first month of
what's happened as a result of the work
we did with the doctors at BC on a new
doctor agreement on the new to practice
doctors the tripling of the practice
ready assessment programs the new spaces
at UBC Medical School the the new
medical school that'll be coming to
Simon Fraser University these are all
steps that we continue to take equally
for nurses and importantly for nurses
steps to both retain nurses at all
because that is obviously critically
important but a significant increase in
treeing spaces for nurses for Health
Sciences professionals again same
increase in training spaces increase
increasing opportunities to ladder up
for ambulance paramedics as well and you
saw ambulance paramedics supporting our
most recent Collective Agreement at 96
percent and then healthcare workers the
extraordinary historic really success of
the hcap program which was put in place
during the pandemic to provide more care
in long-term care and in home care and
home support there are challenges in
some smaller communities where the
opening of facility depends on a
relatively small number of people when
we see as we see in the Health Care
System
continued higher levels of illness which
can have an impact and when it is not
safe to operate in a certain way we
can't operate in that way but our plan
in Merit just as our plan in Port Hardy
and in other communities is to take
action to support those communities and
to see to see that those problems which
have been occasional problems but
significant problems whenever they
happen in community communities and
there's certainly significant in Merit
we see the same approach that we took
for example in Clearwater you'll
remember last year Richard there was a
lot of discussion on that through to
September 2nd there hasn't been a
closure since September 2nd because we
took a systematic action that community
in Port Hardy the plan that we've put in
place a significant plant we put in
place to support
all of the three hospitals in that
region
are are I think you're seeing already
the impact of that the opening of
long-term care beds the improvements of
support for people dealing with
addictions issues the hiring of new
staff and the work that's going on there
so I I think it's fundamental to provide
Health Care in rural BC these issues are
coming that do come and we've seen it
now a number of occasions in Merit and
the Interior Health Authority is engaged
to make sure that we have permanent
Solutions not just short-term Solutions
permanent Solutions to ensure that when
people need care wherever they live
whether it's in Merit whether it's in
Clear Water whether it's in Port Hardy
or whether it's in Vancouver or New
Westminster or Prince George that they
have the health care that they need
next question is for Zhou Globe and Mail
please go ahead
thanks uh this is foreign minister Dix
the federal government is calling back
uh 82 million in health funding mostly
related to diagnostic services including
about 23 million for BC
um what action to this uh call back and
why is BC allowing these charges to
patients thanks well uh it's quite the
country of that I I do
um you know I would say
um in the nicest possible way to the
federal government that provincial
government has taken about 100 actions
on health human resources and we need
them to act in areas where they have
significant jurisdiction to assist in
the health human resources situation
immigration which which where the
progress is frequently glacial I would
say with respect to the Canada Health
act since 2017 taking action again and
again this is particularly true in
diagnostic care
and British Columbia takes the process
seriously we report seriously on the
results here
and uh and the federal government
enforces the Canada Health act
intermittently across the country I
would say with respect to diagnostic
care for example because the significant
part of this is MRIs in 2017 the 1617
fiscal year we did 174 000 MRI exams in
BC what that meant was the development
of a private sector because the previous
government
pushed a two-tier system of diagnostic
care we've changed that with the most
dramatic change I think we've ever seen
here we've gone from 174 000 a year to
three hundred thousand a year we've
added MRI machines our MRI machines are
full to use their full extent that is 24
7 in nine cases in BC it was only one
before and at least 1907 in 19 cases in
addition we've purchased some of those
private MRI machines to support the
public system and added MRI machines
across the province in addition to that
we've brought into Force provisions of
the Medicare protection act some of
which we are interrupted in putting into
Force by by some uh restrictions in a
court case we were dealing with it's um
that with the Camby Surgical Center so
we've taken actions on the law we've
taken actions on diagnostic care taken
actions on surgery we've brought um uh
contracted healthcare workers back into
the public system there's no level of
government in Canada no Province
including the federal government that
has taken so much action and made so
much investment to make the Public
Health Care system work and to bring
people back into the public system and
we're really very very proud of that
record
did you have a follow-up
well yes I do thank you the minister
says he wants provinces to ensure that
patients are not being charged for
health care services in particular
virtual care what is BC doing to prevent
these types of charge charges from
private operators enforcing the Medicare
protection act which we changed we
brought in provisions of the Medicare
protection act by regulation as you know
there's been some to talk about some
particular issues that tell us a health
situation which I referred to the
Medicare Medical Services Commission is
now the subject of Court action we've
but more important than this you know
people have this discussion of well we
should have rules to block certain
things we've expanded the access to
public services
when you have just so people understand
because we're talking about diagnostic
care when you only do 174 000 MRI exams
which previous government had done when
you have one-third per capita the number
of MRI exams in the northern health
authority as they had in Ontario then
you what you're saying to people is that
for a small amount of money you can get
an MRI item privately then come back in
the public system so we've changed that
by providing better service in the
public system by using our public health
equipment more by hiring and training
more staff that's the way to do it and
I'd say this is the federal government
and everybody else we believe and we
know that and especially in the case of
diagnostic care having a public system
that does exactly what we've done 240
000 more CT scans a hundred and on an
annualized basis and in terms of MRI
scans 126
000 more in a short period that's how
you do it you deliver outstanding
service in the public system because
that's what it's all about people who
are waiting for a diagnosis getting
access to that diagnosis and I remind
everyone to look at the facts on these
questions I hear people talk about hip
and knee Replacements I hear them talk
about Diagnostics we've gone from near
the bottom of the country in these
categories to near the top of the
country by those very specific
Investments
news 11 30.
30. either this question is for Minister
dicks I'm asking on behalf of a
colleague who's doing a story about a
young woman who is diagnosed with cancer
and the doctors said to her before she
started treatment that she should have
egg retrieval done because the treatment
would impede her ability or affect her
fertility and was or that it's not
covered at all through MSP and I'm
wondering is there any way for someone
to get that kind of financial assistance
in a situation like this where their
fertility will be negated essentially by
treatment to keep them alive well
um you know in terms of individual case
now
um as as you know Lisa talk uh
specifically about them I'm I'm of
course always interested and open to
hearing people's experiences
um positive and their struggles with the
health care system so I'd be happy to
take a look at it those decisions are
Guided by by health professionals the
decisions we make including with respect
to what's covered by the medical
services plan and as you know we've seen
this in different areas that evolved the
first question I received was about
access to the drug ozympic and the drug
ozempic changed and with respect to
access in December and in in a
significant way so one can review these
things so these these decisions are
Guided by the advice of medical
professionals and but obviously if
people have concerns to bring forward be
happy to take a look at it
Lisa did you have a follow-up
and so I guess I would just clarify so
you would suggest that someone in this
situation or this woman in particular
should go to the ministry and say hey
would you reconsider my unique
circumstances no I I think what it is is
if people have concerns they should
bring them forward and
um every day
um that happens right is bring them
forward and we can look at policy
questions but ultimately the advice will
be guided by medical professionals as it
should be with respect to different
treatments and different kinds of care
there's that is how the Medical Services
Commission Works how the Ministry of
Health Works how the health authority
Works in these sort of matters so I
think probably if I understood the case
you're talking about a treatment a set
of treatment decisions and the policies
that guide those treatment decisions I'm
saying people have issues to raise about
that they can raise them and the changes
do get made I'm not saying they will in
this case obviously you have to look at
the details but what I am saying is
those decisions and what's covered and
what what we do and how we for example
triage
issues is uh is Guided by health
professionals as it should be
our next question is for Katie DeRosa
Vancouver son please go ahead
hi Minister uh thanks for taking my
question on the issue of a Physicians
who have signed on to the new payment
model
um are you are you happy or what's your
thoughts about the number who have
um I know about 50 still have not so
what does that say about whether the
payment model is attractive and also the
number of new doctors we're seeing
through the um New to practice uh
incentives
well I I was trying to figure out how
one could spin that uh for it to be
anything other than a breathtaking
success but but yeah but uh but there
was and then I got your question uh
Katie so I appreciate that and I
appreciate the way you phrase it and
it's good to respond to it
um uh it's an exceptional success I mean
more than 2 100 physicians in a
fundamental change to the way we provide
um primary care in the province so a
change that will benefit patients across
the province it's a phenomenal success
so far remember it's important to put in
context what that is because not all
positions were on chief of service prior
to this but of all those that practice
what we call longitudinal primary care
about 48.7 percent of existing
Physicians have already signed on in the
first month which is a breathtaking
success not all of the remainder wrong
fee for service it should be understood
secondly we've added I think about 167
who were not billing our own latitudinal
family practice last year which is in
the first month an exceptional success
when you look at the relative number of
people practicing communities which
would be uh in the 35 36 3700 range and
the total number of primary care doctors
who are 6 800. so it has been a
breathtaking success so far this is a
transformation people have been waiting
for years for this to happen
79 78 percent of Billings were on FIFA
service in BC last year 70 79 we had the
highest level of fee for service in the
country so this is this is a movement
within a month that puts us from the
most fee for service to the massive move
to a new payment model which is uh
significant so it's breathtaking and the
reason it's a positive thing and the
reason is good for patients and the
reason we've seen so many doctors join
already is because
we worked on it together and this was a
joint initiative that we worked on
together that recognizes the work that
family doctors do in the community
reflects that in their compensation but
also reflects the type of work they do
we're asking family doctors in addition
to everything else to train more new
family doctors and to supervise more new
family doctors we have to recognize that
in training finally I'd say because
there's questions earlier about rural
doctors the same agreement has made
significant improvements for that group
of practitioners as well so I'm I I just
can't tell you how delighted I am about
how it's gone and that doesn't mean
there aren't going to be challenges
because it's a that fundamental a change
that we've seen in a short period of
time they're going to be lots of
challenges there's going to be
occasionally Dr s room it doesn't work
finally I'd say there are some doctors
who are on group contracts now and they
a lot of those may be moving over in the
coming months so it hasn't stop going up
I think it was about 2141 today and I
expect that number to continue to go up
and uh boy it's a it's a significant
significant achievement that isn't my
achievement it's the achievement of all
those that worked on this including the
doctors at BC themselves
Katie did you have a follow-up
uh yes uh you know the federal
government Minister du Khloe sent out
sort of a letter to the provinces
yesterday reaffirming the commitment to
publicly funded health care and
announced the the deductions for the
provinces related to uh patient uh
charges you know he did mention that BC
got a bit of a reimbursement uh so what
does that say about uh BC's efforts to
remove some services that were you know
like MRIs from the private system and
also if you can can you give us an
update on the injunction against teles
health
um will uh with respect to the latter
it's it's a matter before the courts and
it's being uh worked out uh there uh in
terms of
um in terms of uh what it says uh first
of all remember the whole issue of MRIs
wasn't in these deductions prior to that
I think the steps that BC have taken on
MRIs are well known everywhere
um you talk to people uh on the street
people tell me about the MRIs they now
have at three in the morning how happy
they are to get them because it means
they get their MRI sooner and the fact
that we've significantly increased the
number of public MRIs and necessarily
understanding is there was a report a
while ago that treated many of those
public MRIs as if they weren't public
MRIs because Radiologists get got paid
through group contracts on fee for
service they're all public MRIs we've
seen this very significant increase
we've purchased private MRIs no
jurisdiction has done more on this issue
than BC and we're going to continue to
take it seriously into take action to
ensure that people get the service they
deserve in the public system and this
was a major failing of the Health Care
System prior to 2017 that we addressed
and were addressing and we're not we
don't turn away from it we're taking the
action that's required because I think a
lot of people think it's a legal
question you should stop people from
doing things I think we should provide
outstanding service in the public system
and that's on MRIs on CT scans but we
are absolutely committed to doing
question is for
eign
three years ago today at your press
conference you announced that there was
seven new cases of covid detected and a
total of 39 positive cases in the
province I guess as you turn your mind
back to three years ago today and all
the upheaval that Society has been
through did you have any sense that
there would have been society and all of
us would have gone through so much over
the intervening three years
yeah really good question you know I I
think about the pandemic in in kind of
three phases and there was the
pre-vaccination phase and and the the
uncertainty phase in the phase where we
were
um didn't know what was going to happen
um and uh in that phase what you're
talking about uh I still had some hope I
guess that we would be able to push this
virus back into uh back into nature like
we did with the SARS outbreak in in 2003
um by the summer of 2020 it became clear
that that was not possible and that this
was going to go on and then I think of
the the vaccination phases are sort of
second phase of the virus and having
vaccines within a within a year was just
amazing and and a miracle
um didn't have enough soon enough but
and you know that was a very challenging
time too you and then this last year in
a bit has really been the Omicron phase
where things really changed again so
um if I you know having spent a lot of
my life in pandemic planning mostly
based on influenza I had scenarios that
we had thought through and ideas of of
how they would might play out and I
think what has really really
shocked me surprised me I guess is going
through all these phases we've gone
through about every single scenario that
we had imagined could happen so I did I
think no relatively early on that we
were going to have a period of great
uncertainty and we were looking at what
was happening in China we looked at what
was happening in in Italy and the the
terrible tragedies that happened there
in places that got hit really early on
in and hadn't taken measures to try and
protect especially those who are most at
risk so
I think I I had a sense that we would
have a period of time where we would all
have to take some very drastic measures
to protect those who were so much at
risk but as I mentioned earlier I you
know finding that balance was so
challenging and going on for so long in
the scenarios changing so much was the
hardest part about this I think and and
hard on everybody and I absolutely
recognize that we we have all suffered
through this and it has affected us
um and I talk a lot about it has exposed
some inequities in our society and if we
think back to you know this time three
years ago
how much we realized we depend not only
on health care workers but on grocery
store workers on people who work in
pharmacies the people that pick up our
garbage you know that these are
important parts of our lives and that
these are our workers who may not have
been valued in the way that we needed to
recognize them and so if I think about
the things that
that made a difference in addressing
some of those inequities I think about
the fact that we we had that we have
mandatory said leave
and I talked way back in March of 2020
about you know telling people what we
need you to do telling giving you the
data saying why we need you to do it but
giving people the means and telling
people to stay home when they're sick
when they can't feed their child or they
can't have no way of they don't have any
sick leave they have no way of staying
home without losing their job so I I
think we've we've seen a lot in society
that we I hope will continue to work
together to address
I worry that we're forgetting already
some of those things that are so
important in our social connectedness in
our in our society so that is something
that that we in public health are going
to continue to advocate for and to focus
on
kind of a long answer sorry
yeah thank you yeah by way of follow-up
I guess I'm wondering if it's still
declared a pandemic by the World Health
Organization we've talked about it as
such when do you think it will no longer
be declared a pandemic as a practical
matter what will happen when it's no
longer declared as such and I also I
guess I'm also wondering
um
if you have any specific
place whether it's as it relates to
children I know this is with the benefit
of hindsight but as we look forward to
the legacy of covert there'll be some
good and there will be some bad
um do you have something you wish you
could do differently regarding
restrictions
um
so it you know it when the pandemic
phase and the emergency phase of the
pandemic is overnight I think probably
as we head into the summer unless things
change dramatically we'll see that
happen and I think I hope that we'll be
able to remove the public health
emergency around the pandemic and start
to but that doesn't mean that kovid's
gone and we don't have to do things
anymore it means that we're at a level
of the level of uncertainty has
decreased and the changes are happening
in a much more slowly and manageable way
so covet is still going to be with us
sarsko V2 this virus is part of our our
lexicon now it's part of our life it's
another vaccine preventable disease
that we will have to pay attention to
for the foreseeable future so it is
putting it in that context as we emerge
we're still not out of respiratory
season but I hope and I expect to given
you know history that in the nearly end
of March into April we will be and then
we look at okay well where are we now
what are the things that we need to have
in place
in terms of restrictions you know some
of the things that I'll I'll turn it a
little bit differently
um you know we didn't do some of the the
lockdowns that were done in other
jurisdictions if you recall even during
the the period of greatest uncertainty
early on we provided advice to people
but we tried to find the balance like
going outside knowing that that was a
lower risk finding ways that people
could do these important social
connections that we need in our lives in
a way that protected those who are most
at risk we open schools in June of 2020
and schools remained open I think that
was such an important thing we know that
young people need that safe environment
that structure in their lives that the
social interactions that come with
schools and having the measures that we
had in place in schools and and again I
I give credit to our committee but to
the superintendents and principals and
teachers and families the school
communities who really came together and
recognized how important it was for
children to be in those settings and to
continue to learn through this Pandemic
those are the things that are really
important and that I think we did a
really good job on some of the things
that we may not
remember is you know we tried to keep as
much open as possible as safely as
possible and part of the strategy behind
that was the covet safety plans and so
covet safety plans were what allowed us
to do so much more on an ongoing basis
the the time period though that that was
the most difficult
for for me for all of us in terms of
decision making was really the Delta
period
and that was in the fall late summer of
I don't even know what year I'm in now
of 2021 and into the fall and winter of
2021 just before Omar Khan
so once we had vaccination we started to
see that dramatic decrease in in illness
particularly in older people and you
know just how wonderful that was and
through that summer we were in a place
that I was hopeful I think all of us
were really hopeful it was in a place
where we wouldn't be able to to start
getting back to more of the activities
that we needed and we took a cautious
approach and I think that was important
and and I stand by that but when Delta
came
it was hitting young people they were in
emergency departments there were these
were people who were not yet vaccinated
for very often it was it was such a
difficult it was a very severe disease
in very many people and particularly in
the North and the interior where we had
to Medevac hundreds of people in
critical care most of them with co-fit
the places in this that was the hardest
hardest time and we were all tired and
we were all tired of this and you know I
think I can't remember whose quote it
was but you know I think it was
Churchill is when you're in the middle
you know up hard Everything feels like
failure and I think that was a very
challenging time and again I lift my
hands up to communities who supported
each other and I think a lot about the
communities in the north who had such a
difficult officer
assistant it's such a challenging time
for everybody
you know talking with the communities in
the north who banned it together and
supported each other through that period
of time in particular so you know
there's so many stories that we have
lived through together in this last
three years
thank you everyone that's all the time
we have for today